welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
boss in the time variance authority of
Loki is a world many of us are
revisiting ahead of Loki season 2
especially after guanamania and as my
favorite MCU setting I've always had a
ton of questions about how these
workplaces are created who makes the
decisions over what we see on the
desktop screens what it all looks like
what search engine restrictions are on
Casey's computer and why Miss minutes is
such a little tease with that finger
wagon well these decisions are often
made by Motion Graphics artists and user
interface designers at companies like
Cantina and we actually found one of
these artists who had a very interesting
history with the famous Thanos multiple
choice question and lots of other
insights into how the world of the TBA
was designed here's our conversation
about that fascinating design process
behind the TDA and Loki and this video
is brought to you by Squarespace more on
them later so let's welcome to New
rockstars a user interface designer who
has helped design the technology of
things that you've seen in the time
variants Authority on Marvel's Loki and
for stuff that you've seen in Black Adam
for the DC Universe Darby vicento
welcome to New rockstars Darby thanks
for talking with us today what's up guys
so uh tell us what exactly you do
because it's a complicated job it sounds
like from people in the outside world
who don't even know that this type of
work is being done they might just take
it for granted yeah so our stuff is in
um a niche of a niche of a niche so
technically the general term for what I
do is Motion Graphics and then below
that there is user interface design so
there's people who design interfaces for
your phones and for computers so any
kind of Technology you interact with
somebody designed that experience and
made an anime design that made it look
pretty and then there's the niche of
that which is a futuristic user
interface for TV and film which is hyper
specialized
um so that's where I fall in and
everybody I work with and so we designed
Screen Graphics for movies and TV
for future Tech stuff that doesn't exist
or in the case of Loki older Tech and we
try to help Elevate the story with the
graphics it's so interesting because
when I think of Loki I think of yeah it
is kind of this weird hybrid of older
Tech that of course is futuristic in
nature but it has to have a weathered
feel to it right yeah it's gonna feel
dirty and grungy and old and yeah what
how does how does one get involved in
this kind of work I think everybody has
a different story from who I've talked
to in this but uh my story was kind of
weird I reached out to a dude in email
uh when I was in high school and his
name was Jace Hansen and he designed the
Iron Man heads-up displays and the
helmet with all the holographic stuff
going on and we kind of became friends
back and forth to talk for a few years
and then I was in college
and I was doing this stuff as a hobby on
the side of my dorm room and Jace was
like hey bro you should drop out of
school I think you could totally do this
full time so I left school and I moved
up to Vegas and hung out with Jay's for
like three months and we hung out and
designed every day and he kind of taught
me his process and then I moved back to
Tennessee where I'm from and uh Jace uh
kind of vouched for me at the studio
called Cantina creative where he did all
the Iron Man stuff at and uh they were
like yeah let's Trial By Fire Let's just
throw them on something and so that's
how I got in that's so interesting um
but it just sounds like there's a lot of
creativity that's involved with it and
that's what I want to like highlight as
much as I can on this channel is like
shining a light on and appreciating just
the Artistry that goes into this process
and so let's you worked uh you worked on
a team with Loki with season one of Loki
uh and can you just walk us through the
steps of how you worked with Marvel to
design this interface that we saw within
the TVA yeah so I'm a freelance
contractor so I get caught on per
project and all my projects have been
through Cantina creative they're awesome
we have a fun relationship so I don't
work directly uh with Marvel I'm not
sitting in a room talking to them sure
they'll talk to Cantina and the record
the people appointed on the show and
then they translate that communication
to me and so in this case Donna Cohen uh
Tony lupoy and Andrew Harlock were kind
of the three people leading the ship on
Loki and so Andrew was our design lead
and he would kind of communicate with me
what they want what they wanted to
change
and so when we're kind of going through
this process we'll get the shots in from
Marvel they'll tell they'll be a blank
screen we'll have a rough edit of kind
of what they want story beat wise there
and then we kind of go at it uh give two
or three versions to them and then
Andrew and Donna and Tony will kind of
present it look for feedback and then
Marvel will give us sometimes first try
it's great sometimes we get a bunch of
feedback and they want to kind of change
everything either way is expected and
it's fine but that's kind of that
collaborative process so I see okay so
you're presenting three different
versions and can you give an example of
like was it a piece of technology or
something seen on a screen in the TVA uh
yeah so I mean we're uh there's a term
called previz uh and so there's previous
for uh CG where it's something really
rough just to kind of give a sense of
story and beat when you're getting rough
footage for us Mark well specifically
with Marvel they have their own previous
Department in-house and so they'll kind
of doodle some graphics on their slaps
and stuff on the screen just so we have
an idea of what they kind of want so for
example if it's the Chrono monitor they
might draw a line in like three branches
saying we want three branches here
something like that that's kind of how
we kind of get a rough idea I gotcha so
uh when we watch the episodes of low-key
season one I think a lot of people are
going back to re-watch Loki right now
you can see like little Easter eggs on
the desktop streams like it's like it's
like watching the office a lot of
characters just playing Solitaire on
their screen or specifically like we
don't really know how much to read into
this but right uh places and locations
and time dates that ticker across the
the ticker how are those details chosen
yeah so there's not a global answer for
all of that so for example like uh with
locations or dates a lot of that will
come from Marvel saying hey we'd love to
throw this in here and then sometimes
it's just hey can we just film locations
because three of these are important the
rest are kind of similar so it's really
give or take but with things like the
solitary screen that you were talking
about we kind of just go at it and have
fun because I mean our jobs to World
build really and so we're looking at
these screens I'm thinking man like you
know I think Andrew was the one who
ended up putting the solitary thing in
there for fun and you know we'll show it
too and I think it's funny and they love
it they're like yeah like we didn't even
think about that let's do it you know
conversations like that are so organic
so our job is to get them thinking you
know so throwing things in there like
that helps them kind of think a little
bit uh little bit bigger than maybe they
were thinking originally about the
screen interesting I liked hearing how
collaborative it is because you know
it's also if you think about a show like
Loki you know with with he remains
revealed at the end it's all from his
mind but what I like about is hearing
that there's a lot of artists who are
weighing in on this it kind of presents
like it it makes the TV feel more like I
don't know it gives it more variety and
more kind of true bureaucracy office
feel to it did you ever mix in anything
and the options you put in there that
might have been rejected for being like
oh no no we can't mention that thing
like because they'll they'll read into
it if you do that
uh yes I think so but uh I don't know if
I can actually say what it is it's fair
enough but fair enough
where they're like hey who put this in
there and I'm like I don't know who did
that
uh now one detail that we spotted if you
can't talk too much about it it's fine
this multiple choice question about
Thanos and like the fact that like
Thanos has two apples like he goes back
in time to eat another one like yeah you
don't have to get if there's anything
qualifications about from that that's
fine I just curious how did that come
about yeah no I can talk about that
um okay I'm actually really excited that
you asked me about it and because I
watched your breakdown okay of that
episode and you pointed out that screen
and I got so excited and I said it to
like all my friends and stuff and I'm
like he's on my screen because oh that
was you yeah it was me well yeah I mean
like everybody touches everything but
that joke thing there was
I believe for that screen they wanted it
to be like a DMV questionnaire kind of
thing I think that was the original ask
and so Andrew and I were kind of going
back and forth like just spitballing a
bunch of different designs and we landed
on one and so they wanted like these
questions and here in Tennessee growing
up there's this test called the TCAP
that you take in elementary school and
it's like the most ridiculous questions
on Earth it's like hey Sally has 800
skateboards and she breaks half of them
and then one of them rolls down the hill
and four of them get blown away in a
tornado but she finds two of them how
many does she have you know there's just
something ridiculous like that so I was
thinking man that'd be so funny if those
were the questions here for the TVA and
so I came up with something that it was
similar to what you see in the show this
like Thanos Apple thing and
at this time I was a newer artist so I
was kind of scared to like write
something funny because I didn't I
didn't know if it'd be received well but
we set it off to to uh the director and
the show Runners and the VFX people and
they looked at it we got a note back
saying that they thought it was so funny
and they asked me to write 30 more jokes
so I did that 38 times making up
different questions about Thanos and
apples and paradoxes or whatever and
they ended up they picked their favorite
options we put them on the screen and
then ended up in the show and like you
know it's kind of like in the back you
really gotta look for it but I mean I
wrote so many jokes for that so when you
notice it I got so excited like yes
I think that was my favorite Easter egg
in all of Loki like well I just did a
revisitation of it on our second Channel
The Deep dive and literally I spent like
a solid three minutes just talking about
each option because like I think this is
just so interesting how this reflects
like the he remains process in the
timekeepers process of just like pruning
things down to one to one final option
of a sacred timeline like that you have
three options one is like grandfather
Paradox one is multiple timelines one is
more of like just kind of a loose
interpretation of time travel it really
is like such a well thought out question
that forces you to think about the logic
of the show thanks
that's so funny now I'm glad somebody
noticed it it was so funny watching you
react I'm like ah you saw my joke
that's so cool uh now I want to talk
about the color palette of it because
you know when you watch the when you see
that it's so hard to even read what's on
the screen at first because you know
when they uploaded Disney plus sometimes
the compression just kind of makes it a
bit blurrier but like they have you have
this like warm black background orange
fuzzy kind of texture to all the text
how how did that design process come
about yeah so that was
first like real product so Andrew kind
of led the way earlier on with design
exploration and figuring out what works
and what doesn't and a lot of the Amber
stuff was coming from the TVA itself
because a lot of their props and set
design was playing off that orange a lot
of their logos and the way they even
shot stuff the whole show was very warm
and so when we were digging into that
Andrew already kind of had this color
palette once I showed up and that burnt
orange is the primary color this like
monochromatic thing and we kind of
played into it because a lot of the old
dos screens had that as a display I
think it was like blue there was blue
there was an orange one like a green uh
color that was very popular back in you
know before I was born
but yeah playing into that the that
Amber color really is playing off the
TVA itself this bureaucratic uh Brown
and orange primarily color scheme
interesting it sounds like you had to do
a lot of research or your team had to
kind of look back and actual photographs
in the way like offices were designed
back then so you talk about like the
research process that went into the
design of it and it sounds I want to
loop back the research process that you
had writing the 30 different options of
the multiple choice question well okay
to answer your first part the the
research uh like I said like Angie was
really leading the way on that so once I
showed up he was like hey here's all
this stuff I've done and here's kind of
these conclusions we've come to and when
I joined we were still trying to narrow
down what the designs would actually
look like in the final of the show so
we're still exploring but he really had
a strong language and a lot of stuff he
was pulling from those old CRT screens
oscilloscopes uh Old Airport monitors
that show departures and arrivals the
way they're organizing a lot of lines of
different text uh Nintendo DS's for the
Tim pad that was a reference that we had
um a seismograph that you would use to
like measure an earthquake with a little
needle kind of going up and down to show
a passage of something and uh dos
obviously in terminal screens so those
were kind of the real world reference
that we would say pictures of or look at
how do these when you're turning on an
oscilloscope how does it turn on how
does it react to stuff I know Andrew
really leaned into that for the little
happy face that takes off Loki's clothes
at episode one oh yeah him and uh Tony
lupoy is our compositor so his job is to
take our graphics and track them and
make them look realistic and interact
well and I know him and Andrew like
really collaborated on that trying to
make it feel really fuzzy and blurred
and really like it's in the glass and so
they really studied micro details of how
that stuff worked so that's kind of our
reference yeah yeah I love that face
that takes his clothes off because he
looks a little drunk like he looks like
I can handle this like it's like the
worst person to give you a TSA pat down
I'm like please don't touch me right now
but uh but but yeah to follow back up on
the on the process the research process
of writing the multiple choice time
travel logic stuff to be completely
honest I remember the first pass I did I
was just kind of spitballing stuff you
know just my general Marvel knowledge of
how it worked and I was going to make up
questions and I didn't know how visible
it'd really be and then once Marvel kind
of read it and thought it was funny they
asked for a lot of specifics they asked
me to include questions about
grandfather Paradox and I want to say it
was Kate the director maybe specifically
asked for that like trying to give us
like she was like hey why don't we
include this terminology and this idea
and so that's when I started doing
research into well how would this make
sense if this was being asked what's the
context here and how can I make this
real and believable for a screen that
you know only Eric Voss will see but how
how can I make that feeling
but again what I like about it is like
when we shine a light there we see that
there was a lot of like hard work that
went into putting something there for us
to find I think that is the most
rewarding part of my job is like finding
the rewarding parts of your job you know
plus in the smiley face that we were
talking about on the robot uh I know
Andrew
30 40 faces and they all look completely
different and did everything and then
the one that we landed on is the one in
the show but nobody sees the process of
us doing a million versions and figuring
it out and talking about it and getting
to where we're at it's really rewarding
once you finally see it out there yeah
for sure and it's also interesting to
hear that Kate Herron requested the the
grandfather Paradox to put in because I
think even when you watch he remains
monologue at the end it's so super
interpretive and you don't really get a
sense of like it's it's just hard to
draw any firm conclusions about what
Marvel's bigger plan would be but it is
cool just to see like you know Kate
wanted that to be a multiple choice
option you know like it's not saying
this is a plan it's multiple choice so
like it's still just like hey this is
one way it could go Marvel it's like
this is like a pitch to to fight you
like hey a b or c which one is he one
like I think that was the beauty of it
is that it's not it's not saying really
anything
yeah if anything the fact that it is a
multiple choice question tells us
something like it's like I compared it
to like the Blade Runner void comp test
like this is like are you playing ball
with us by making this Choice like what
does this say about you it's like a
horse shark like how do you see what
we're doing test look we're gonna get
back to the video in one second but I
gotta tell you about Squarespace not
only are they making it possible for me
to make this video they could also be
making it possible for you to do
honestly whatever you want to do online
that's because Squarespace makes it easy
to make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything you need your products the
content you create even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales and hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff well no problem you
can display posts from any profile you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing squarespace's analytic tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from and so you can
improve your website and build a
marketing strategy based on either your
top keywords or your most popular
products and content head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain so the TVA in the in the Loki
series it's a Fantastical setting it is
based on the Marvel Comics but it's also
just very different it's its own thing
um did and you mentioned calling that
screen the Chrono monitor like did you
have other in-house terminology for the
places in the equipment that your team
was creating you know I think from I
mean at least from what I can remember
we were given the names of the props and
of the tech we'd be doing pretty early
on so I mean we've come up to Kernel
Monitor and the tin pad or TVA monitors
or there's this term we have called gak
um and gak is just like anything that
looks like it's doing something so TV8
was like all the background monitors and
the background screens and all the
consoles that they're using up in the
the main control room
um so yeah I mean we were using their
terminology pretty early on there was
not really like any kind of uh
internal conversation happening I was
not a part of this but the sequence at
the end uh with he who remains and the
the fluid morphing showing how he kind
of like started doing his stuff that was
not me but Andrew kind of oversaw that
with some Houdini artist that Cantina
brought on that were super talented and
I think for that sequence they kind of
had like their own terminology for what
was being said
um because I don't even know if we knew
the name of that
I think we just called it fluid morph or
whatever something that I mean I have so
many theories and ideas about what that
stuff is and I'm still endlessly
fascinated by just the way it works and
the fact that it has like the golden
kitsuki crack pattern in there like his
cat like it's just so interesting
um the I mean the production design of
Loki is just like endlessly fascinated
to go back through it and find the the
Artistry that went into it and I love
this idea that you talked about the
Chrono monitor line as almost like a
like a seismograph like the idea that
like they look at it as Like An
Earthquake line like oh God something is
rupturing yeah the vaults are breaking
apart like did you have any other
conversations about the people who use
this technology in the world and how
that would affect their functionality or
the way it's designed like was character
part of it yeah for sure I
what was interesting is really the
character that was a part of the design
was not the people it was mainly just
thinking that Miss minutes was eos that
was kind of running across the TPA it's
not like she was a Jarvis character but
there was this there's playful moments
where like the tin pads low on battery I
think it's an episode three and she's
kind of wagging her finger you know like
little little things like that they're
just kind of funny
um I kind of thought of it uh or I think
we kind of thought of it as like this
dos terminal system that everybody uses
however there's just different logins
that could open up different restricted
files and so just like how everybody in
a corporate setting would have Windows
on their computer the CEOs would
definitely have an admin access to
everything but they wouldn't have a
different OS it'd be the same thing some
things that we kind of thought about it
where maybe Mobius had you know his Tim
pad and rensselaer's Tim pad look the
exact same but rinselayer may have
access to forbidden files that Mobius
can't get to right because she's a
higher ranking officer that's kind of
how I thought about it logically yeah
that makes a lot of sense and it seems
like you need to kind of know this like
to just to come up with the idea of the
the finger wagginess minutes I think
that's so interesting like did you start
to anthropomorph I mean Miss minutes is
already anthropomorphized she is a
cartoon clock who can talk it seems to
have thoughts and feelings did that like
did you ever feel like you have a
workplace relationship up with a
character like that as you're designing
this stuff like are you imagining what
her inner thoughts are what her inner
world may be yes and no I mean we don't
really see a lot of Miss minutes
interacting with the tech she's really
displayed through that 3D character
which was done by the people at Luma
they're awesome they did a killer job on
her
um and so she's really expressed through
that but the few times we see her that I
did there was a login screen in episode
one in the main Circle room and Loki
first gets brought in and she's kind of
wagging her finger and there's a login
thing in the back and then I think with
the Tim PAD as well so those little
pop-ups are to me uh just a reminder
that that there's like this there's this
interconnected Network really of like
information through the TVA so
everybody's able to pull information and
check on stuff and uh it made it to me
at least it made it feel more connected
it made it feel like everybody was kind
of running off this interface that was
receiving and sending out information
yeah yeah and what's cool about watching
it is it feels like characters are both
they have access like there's a whole
lived-in world of this uh bureaucracy
but there's also red tape to it right
like the fact that rensslayer in the
finale is even like given the wrong
information than what she requested it's
like well then it's just kind of
maddening we can relate with that
frustration of working somewhere it's
like why don't I have access to what I
need to do my job yeah exactly
um the I think what what was arrived at
for the imagery of the the sacred
timeline of the chronometer screen with
like just the one line and then branches
that snake off of it I cannot I cannot
credit uh everyone who worked on the
show more with just giving us like a
kind of 3D rendering or even a 2D
rendering of what the Multiverse looks
like yeah because that's something that
we're always looking for like can you
just give us a map of where everything
is and
so like what are the conversations like
when it comes to what color that line is
what shape it is how thick it is how to
animate the branches forming or getting
pruned like how they rewind I just I
want to be a fly on the wall for that
conversation I can give you a little
insight so the so like I said when I
came on Andrew had a really strong
language for what the stuff was going to
look like in the beginning and the
Chrono Monitor and the Tim pad in the
beginning looked a lot different than
they look now and we went through a
million different versions and there's
all kinds of ways that we went
eventually Landing where we landed
um but those conversations that you're
talking about where what's the line
thickness what color is going on those
don't happen till later in the process
after we kind of present versions unless
up front they know exactly what they
want with that but I believe for this
show it was very we know it's going to
be branches and there's a sacred
timeline we're trying to figure out a
way to present it and so then we kind of
conceptualize what does that look like
and we'll give them a grounded version
that's really close to their previous
and what they're kind of thinking but
then we kind of go off the rails do
something crazy to see if we can get
them in a different direction and then
they kind of give us feedback and be
trying to meet them in the middle and
try to figure out something that's going
to kind of
number one convey the story I think
that's something that Cantina does a
really great job of is they really want
to make sure the story is conveyed and
that the director's Vision with what the
graphic needs to do is clear otherwise
there's no point for it to be there if
it's not doing anything right like it
either needs to elevate the world or
tell the story point or it's just
wasting wasting space
but then also we want it to feel cool
you know so there's a lot of times that
we'll we'll say hey like we're choosing
this direction because of this real
world real world reference to Dos
monitors or seismographs and that gets
them really excited you know because I
mean who doesn't want that stuff to be
grounded in real life so we ended up
getting to the place with the Chrono
monitor where it's at now uh because
Marvel ended up just really wanting
something simple to tell the story and
we were totally behind it so we kind of
condensed all the stuff that we were
doing into one kind of tidied up package
and it ended up kind of where it's at
now and uh everybody really liked it so
yeah
yeah uh so there was this behind the
scenes documentary Marvel assembled that
talked about how there was uh the
production designers wanted a
three-tiered hierarchy to the TVA you
have like Security in Orange at the
bottom you have management which is like
mobius's level and then you have legal
which is rensselors level was that
structure something you ever kept in
mind like did you think about the you
mentioned having references to to dasis
to to seismographs did you think about
like interoffice communication systems
or like company politics company culture
that kind of stuff uh yes I I for that
um I remember so for example the
Solitaire screen that we talked about
earlier I don't think I've ever gotten
the politics of how would these
characters interact with each other or
have inner drama I suppose but what are
these characters doing and what would
their lives be like because the TVA is
kind of strabby
gross Place nobody really wants to be
there it's kind of gross to look at
through the corridors and always but it
works and so I'm thinking that this guy
who's stuck in this tiny office every
day where the same people come in and
they're surprised that he knows
everything they've ever said and they're
signing these papers what would he
really like be doing on his computer
because I know if I was there I wouldn't
be doing anything
so yeah should you put up Solitaire I
was like that's so perfect like yeah
he's doing absolutely nothing like he's
just playing a game on his computer and
he's like here we go again another guy
let's get him out the door so I think
we're trying to think about characters
in that way uh there was a scene
I couldn't tell the episode but Loki
goes to the library and he talks to his
librarian and uh she's kind of typing on
her computer it's very quick but on that
screen there's she's inputting
information to like an archive kind of
thing like a library and uh what would
she be writing about it's just the most
mundane stuff you know Sally trips on a
rock and that caused a Nexus event and
she's like doing a whole catalog of
stuff just kind of hating her life you
know because I mean she looks so annoyed
when milky shows up and so playing into
that kind of atmosphere is really what
kind of got us into these uh fun
situations yeah absolutely I mean again
this is I I also like just to kind of
um to veg out with my wife we will watch
office the office uh you know and that's
like I just love seeing how Creed is in
the background is playing Solitaire in
most of the shots and when you use ass
what his job is he's like I'm a customer
something uh uh like just these old
people who have been at these desks
forever and ever yeah like they're just
collecting a paycheck at this point yeah
um so we've talked a lot about Marvel
you've worked on other titles too and I
wanted to ask you about your experience
working with Marvel and Disney and how
that differs from how you've worked with
other Studios and other franchises I
think specific with Marvel that sets it
apart from working with other Studios is
their care I mean everybody cares about
their product and so I've never really
worked with anybody who doesn't care uh
but with Marvel and Disney there's this
chain of command where you're talking to
the VFX supervisor so I talked to
Cantina Cantina talks to the VFX
supervisor VFX supervisor talks to the
director and all those people and then
above the director Kevin feige and
Victoria Alonso have to sign off on
everything and so my joke screen for
example gets approved by not only Kate
and the directors but also by upper
Studio owners right whereas for other
Studios the director has a final say
because that's typically how the movie
will be made but Kevin Victoria want a
strong cohesive story and so because of
that they have just much of a voice on
even little screens like this as well as
a big picture and I think because of
that I really enjoy it because
everything is so cohesive and creative
and they love talking about it and the
simplest thing becomes the biggest
conversation it's fun because you can
tell they really care about what they
want it to be I I love that I think it's
still fun working with them if there's
one thing you wish more people knew
about your job and your work what do you
think it would be how I think the joke's
from the good example that there are
these big hero moments that everybody's
really familiar with like the Chrono
Monitor and the Tim pads but there's
these background screens that go through
months of revisions and notes and
changes and conversations just for
people to overlook it because they just
think it's a background screen and I
mean I guess that's really the point is
just for people to really pause and it's
it's for the people who want to pause
and really look into it
um but when you're watching a movie or a
shown you see these screens or Holograms
or Tech someone did that and it wasn't
just thrown together I mean this is a
whole process and so really look at that
stuff and check it out and be like whoa
somebody actually took time to get this
together and to make that I think we're
trying to build the world so it will be
rewarding if you do it because we put
thought into it the studio put thought
into it and it's just going to elevate
your experience if you check it out so
that's great yeah I love that sentiment
I mean that's that's everything that we
try to do here and it's it's just nice
to hear that uh that like our hunting
and our searches and our investigations
are worth it because there is like
valuable stuff to find uh so I really
appreciate all the work you do Darby and
uh kudos to your entire team everyone
you've worked with because obviously a
lot a lot of talent goes into these
things yeah well great and thank you so
much for for talking with us today yeah
man thank you so much I'm super pumped
that we were able to come do this and
hang out that was awesome thank you
again to Darby for talking with us today
and reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive and you can
support this growing Network by grabbing
something from nerdriot.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you